but first we look at the German literary
scene and the favourites for this year's
german book prize six authors have made
it to the final round six works are
shortlisted for the best German language
novel of the year the bets are open but
first it's a good idea to get to know
the lineup the themes the approaches and
the writers themselves Thomas headship
phone-ins Allah time seems to flow at
its own pace in the waters of Berlin's
Hoffa river for 25 years this man has
been visiting a magic realm the foen
insel or peacock island his view of it
is part historical novel part fairy tale
150 initials Rd you don't run into the
hard contradictions of society here you
encounter the fantasies of Dolph d you
find people's wishes and longings
embodied here what interested me was how
my protagonist the [ __ ] Maria dirtiest
rock on deals with this artificial world
la Commons when I couldn't stay in bed
in the early 19th century peacock island
was oppression Elysium a very artificial
one Marie lives here together with
various creatures exotic like herself
it's like a cabinet of Wonders love for
the lady of the manor thought Marie and
wept only in this world of lies but in
the real world a monstrance Marie sense
is that a new era is dawning an era of
progress
nearly bled during her lifetime Darwin
and Mendel made their discoveries the
image of the world changed it was the
rise of imperialism and a rational
approach to the unfamiliar aberrations
were no longer gawked at but classified
and demystified whimsical eccentricity
gave way to the norm what remains an ode
to a past world and its fragile beauty
I'm galing at least offs April a girl
wants to lead her own life but keeps
running into barriers she's a loner and
offends everyone who means her well she
calls a skinny young lady ribs and she
gives herself the name April clewis yeah
Damona decanoate rule is a month that's
just as capricious as April the girl
hail Sun and rain it's pure volatilities
listing behind her is a troubled
childhood in east germany now at 18 she
wants to stand on her own two feet but
April keeps hitting the skids with
alcohol drugs and suicide attempts she
pulls through every time the big 8 net
Lloyd she meets people who take care of
her and I think it's not unimportant
that April was socialized in East
Germany in her early years isness
enlistees
if nothing else socialism did provide
some security but in the 1980s April
feels Walden and applies for an exit
visa she makes it to the west like
loosen Dorf herself did but the
childhood traumas came with her yatin
faked alice by breath sweeps everything
aside the beauty of the past few days
the security she felt and the joy as if
her body were a high-pressure gun with
from which her breath exhaled with
enough force to blow down houses and
people warmth love on David conclusion
Dorf tells of a difficult emancipation
without frills without mercy Gertrude
Lloyd neggers Punisher frühling or panic
spring it's the moment after the
Cataclysm it's 2010 a volcano has
erupted in iceland and suddenly chaos
normality is torn asunder the Swiss
author has put it into a book
so Paul so angry cinch day as soon as a
tear appears we had things are often
possible that you've never dreamt of
before yeah never feared and never hoped
for mr. Hoff that
Europe is unhold in London to a
middle-aged woman is taking time out
from her life she strolls through the
streets as if in limbo and through the
shards of her memories I likha hai shi
de agua the sounds of the awakening city
rose unhindered and downright
triumphantly into the emptiness in
delirium poor she meets a mysterious
young man he's handsome but disfigured
by a birthmark that he could punish of
ruling the title meaning panic spring
recalls pan the ancient Greek Shepherds
God yeah who has two aspects I know
sites fed so on the one hand he be
witches and seduces people on the other
he throws the animals into panic halogen
Tecton this switching back and forth
between near and far and other contrasts
run through the novel
a natural phenomenon provides its rhythm
and the silence afterward it's Wonder
Thomas Mellas 3,000 euros
it's a cold hard look at the present in
a big city a homeless man fallen from
the ranks of the middle class and a
woman a cashier in a discount store
maelys novel deals with life below the
poverty line
that's because although the book has
both furious and tender basic impetus
for my writing comes from rage rage at
things I experience and rage at
conditions in general but I wouldn't say
this is the angriest book I've ever
written it's the students the sizes of
jager Sweden pubs plenty of rage and
tenderness run through Thomas Mellas
cool concise sentences spaghetti
spaghetti tomato paste beer and cat food
the neverending monotony of the products
and cash register beeps have long ceased
to make her dizzy but now the looks do
this time a language should be very
clear the rhetorical running amok that I
produced on occasion had started to bore
me maybe the subtler metaphors are
sometimes more effective effective of
them mellow writes about the outrages of
poverty here and now we're 3,000 euros
can be nothing and everything
two losers she at least dreams of the
future but he only feels homesick
homesick for the past
looks sylars cruzo ten percent land
ninety percent sky that's how zeiler
sees this baltic island it is even de
menthe he didn't say was always a
shangri-la in the days of East Germany
outside I'm actually almost a legend
everybody wanted to go to the island at
least once in their lives Phoenix since
in seinem leave my office in the summer
of nineteen eighty nine it is a student
who's seen tough times and ends up
stranded here working as a tourist
season waiter at the Klausner he meets
kindred souls other outsiders what they
have in common is their yearning for
freedom on this island at the very edge
of East Germany the interests of the
inserts the decision to live on that
island was all they needed to know about
each other that formed an invisible bond
in would insist bhavas by the ones who
were here had left the country without
crossing the border wanna die grenze
super shayatin
at the klausner ed meets cruzo the
island guru although thousands would
leave East Germany for the West that
summer cruise Oh preaches something else
to his castaways of life something
transcending all borders inner freedom
de bolsa de de everyone carries the root
within then ah that's one of the
premises that freedom resides in
everyone wouldn't but it's very
difficult to claim his inheritance
alabanza Clayton loses iler creates a
utopia that's doomed a profound story of
shipwreck with rich imagery and language
Henry Stein fest dear Alice for sure
this author has a fear of heights which
is apparently why he forces himself to
seek them out just like his protagonist
16 brown men Geist my spirit rebelled
and left my body the spirit asked what
are you doing here anyway what is this
lunacy are you a mountain goat and sit
there are many extraordinary situations
in this magical and remarkable work of
literature for me steal mom baby I see
the world of the novel as a parallel
universe let it begin advancing I'm not
the only author to say his character
surprising I don't know everything about
these figures at the outset the
narrative keeps taking unexpected turns
it's kind of pinata the burst over our
heads a treasure trove a very real dream
in Taiwan 16 is struck down by an
exploding whale
as a top executive he'd survived a plane
crash and become a lifeguard at a track
star later he has a son who's not really
his this is Altman this is my gateway to
the world all the big and little things
the seemingly important to seemingly
unimportant it all comes together I
always say I'm not a hunter I'm a
gatherer Jacob have been in Samuel zany
adventurous the Una's for sure the
all-round researcher plays by its own
rules past and present aristocracy and
precariat extraordinary tales of
outsiders this year's lineup of German
language novels covers the range from
whimsical to deadly serious the jury
will be announcing the winner on october
sixth at the opening of the Frankfurt
Book Fair
will be on hand when the decision is
made public
you